this
is from the oregon coronavirus update
the um the newsletter that i get as a
citizen of oregon that i signed up for
um from the oregon department of human
services
january 21st that's two days ago as we
are speaking
we have this headline vaccine voices i
trust the science and the data
is phenomenal i'm going to read the
first sentence only
anna antonopoulos a pediatric
hospitalist in medford shares her
vaccination story
quote i got my coven 19 vaccine to
protect my patients my friends my family
and myself
i've dedicated my life to helping others
around me whether that is treating
patients in the hospital teaching sunday
school at church
being a super aunt to my five nieces and
two nephews and just being a good
neighbor and friend
getting my vaccine is an extension of
this i want to be an example
i trust the science and the data is
phenomenal i was so excited
to get my vaccine
she is making a public health
pronouncement
which is that being a good neighbor
means that you should seriously consider
getting the vaccine
and uh that may well be true
that is different public health is
different from what is the science
what do the science scientific results
actually say
and the quote that this begins with i
trust the science and the data is
phenomenal again i'm going to get a
little
um semantic here and say
what that should read is the data are
phenomenal
um the singular being datum for yeah
data r um but
we talked last week about um there being
i think it was last week a death and
there have been a few
um that seemed to be the result of this
vaccine but there are
many millions of of doses of vaccine
that have been
have been given and um you know it's an
error just as it is with kova to only
talk about deaths but if you just look
at the
the death rate the you know the the rate
of deaths that we
really think could be attributable to
the vaccine it's tiny and there will
always be some risk and
those deaths do not in and of themselves
really suggest any reason to be
particularly skeptical of this vaccine
at all the fact is and we have said this
over and over and over again
that given that the technology with
which the two main vaccines that are
being deployed in the u.s
the mrna vaccines by pfizer and moderna
are
brand spanking new that we simply
cannot have access to data
that suggest long-term safety those data
cannot possibly exist the data are
phenomenal
what data the data on what has happened
in the weeks to coming on you know
almost a month now of many many people
getting this vaccine
so far so good great really hope it
stays that way
but claiming that you should trust the
science and following that immediately
with the data are phenomenal
is disingenuous at best
you you you just can't get there from
here yeah i fully agree with you um the
data can't be phenomenal because
they simply cannot cover one of the very
important issues which is what is the
long-term
uh impact of this on the physiology of
those
uh who have taken the vaccine hopefully
it's uh
a negligible effect but we can't know
that yet and pretending that we do know
it
um is is unacceptable um
i would also say that this is embedded
in a landscape
where the data generation mechanism
is itself captured yeah and
that is very troubling because even when
the data do
seem to suggest a rosy outcome one
cannot be certain whether or not
that is what the data say because that's
actually the
consequence or because the economic
pressure
economic pressures that come from
generating vaccines like this in a
for-profit
context have um steered the journals
have caused
um a you know selection of some data
over others
because they paint a rosier picture i'm
not saying that has happened but we have
seen indications
of it and we've covered them here on the
podcast the fact is
this is not a clean system and if the
next time this happens
we want to be able to say what it is
that the
the data indicate then we need to clean
up that system so that in fact we can
say
you know okay we still wouldn't know
what the long-term impact was but at
least we'd be able to say with some
confidence
that an objective analysis says x y or z
and at this moment we don't have that
because the whole system is driven by
perverse incentives
yeah and it renders pronouncements by
any and all health officials pretty much
a suspect and you know we we should
always
be encouraged to remain skeptical of
pronouncements uh
that we have not ourselves uh
verified or um had people whom we have
come to trust uh go
in and assess those statements uh in
this case
over and over and over again i feel like
we're beginning to sound like a broken
record here but over and over and over
again
we get health professionals of of some
stripe who
have been asked to make a statement
which basically demonstrates to
all the plebes all of us out here why it
is that we need to take this
and there is you know the best possible
gloss that i can put on this
is that there is an intentional fuzzing
of the actual distinction between um
what could the science possibly say
about safety and efficacy of this
vaccine
versus what is the right public health
move for
as many people as possible to do
and those two things it's great when
they're exactly in concert
they often will not be and the fact is
that we deserve
as members of a democracy to
have the information on both fronts what
can we and can we not yet know about
safety and efficacy
and what is it that
we currently think is the best move from
a public health perspective that will
allow us
um to um you know start having a
functioning economy again as soon as
possible
yes well um maybe a couple of
final points we can't say that the data
are phenomenal we can say that they're
going to be phenomenal whether or not
that actually reflects
the uh the um the impact of these
vaccines on people why are the data
the data are going to be very phenomenal
yeah um
okay and the last thing i would say
though is that this brings us back
around
to what we started with we were talking
about the indications out of the very
young biden administration
i mean we talked about several things
that seemed positive rejoining
the who um the uh paris climate of
course paris climate change
yeah and i would just say that in each
of these two i think we need to be
cautious of the same
kind of um the two being the who and the
paris climate accord
uh yes um so the who
uh in principle should the u.s be
uh uh a very active member of
the who sure but there's a question
about whether or not the who is so
compromised by allegiances that in fact
we are
stuck in the position of effectively not
having a
a viable who and the fact of
peter dasik being on the who's
task force to determine the origin of
sars kovi
ii in china is indicative of a deep kind
of corruption
right this is the last person who should
be on that committee and yet
he's there and again most positive gloss
is at the very least there's a conflict
of interest there there's a conflict of
interest and it may be driving and so
um if that is the case then the fact
that symbolically it makes sense to
participate in the world's mechanisms
for navigating health issues and things
like that
is in conflict with what the hell are we
going to do once the mechanisms are
captured we're going to have to do
something
unusual with respect to the paris
climate accords i would say symbolically
speaking
this is great of course we should be
party to global accords on
managing resources like the atmosphere
and protecting us from
heat accumulation on the other hand uh
it ain't a solution right it's more or
less symbolic at the level of its
effectiveness
and if we were ever going to get to
something useful we would have to have a
very frank global discussion and that
would include
figuring out you know what parts of
these models
uh actually indicate something how can
you validate them rather than pretending
that because the computer says that
something's going to happen
that it is what other data can we rely
on in order to calibrate our
belief or lack of belief in the models
etc
so can we promote international efforts
for actual alternative energy etc
right and with respect to uh dapple i
would say
um i was very much not in favor of this
pipeline
i don't like it but um i mean you were
you protested against it yeah i did
um but back in whenever that was like
2016
2016 it would have been um but i want to
know
what the alternative is and i want a net
analysis right the idea of we're not
going to do this because our
constituents
don't like it is not good enough the
answer is well what are we going to do
and you know so uh i'm not interested in
the shell game where we pay
attention to the symbolism over here and
we don't
check out the net effect of the policy
change so in all of these cases i would
say
uh i remain to be convinced um and we
have to move beyond symbolism
and uh you know political corruption and
regulatory capture
are two of the biggest stories of our
era and we
we're gonna have to to find our way out
of the
very deep hole they've dug for us
[Music]
you